You have to find something to like
in the language you're learning.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here once
again talking about language learning,
and I want to talk about what I
would call indirect motivation.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a review.
We do appreciate it.
So we know that we need to be motivated.
I say this all the time.
I hope my videos are motivating.
And everyone understands that if you have
a motivated student, when it comes to
language learning and probably anything
else, that person will learn on their own.
So motivation is the key,
but how do we get motivated?
So, you know, I was thinking
that, uh, you know, I mentioned...
I did a video about my
interest in history.
So I ended up motivated, motivating
myself to learn a language because
I'm motivated to learn history.
So in a sense, the learning of the
language is almost an indirect motivation.
It's not because I want to learn
the language it's I'm interested
in history and therefore I end up
learning the language and, you know,
that's true with so much in life.
Um, if you say, I want to make a lot of
money, uh, maybe you first have to provide
a service, uh, which other people are
willing to pay for, uh, or maybe you have
to be so skilled at what you do, that
you can generate a revenue stream or you
have to be so knowledgeable, in other
words, you have to be good at what you
do so that the direct motivation, even
though what you want to do out there is
make money you have to first build up
your knowledge base, your skill base.
Uh, and you have to have an attitude that
says I'm gonna deliver, you know, value.
Okay.
I'm gonna, if you want to be a
good, uh, Shoemaker to take a
simple example, you, you, you
can't just be motivated for money.
You actually have to enjoy making shoes.
You have to...
the same if you're in the job and your
goal is to do well in the job and to be
promoted, uh, or you're providing some
service and you want to do well with
your, you have a company of your own or
you're working for someone else, you have
to do that job well, that's the direct
objective that you have to achieve.
You have to do that well in order to
achieve the sort of indirect, uh, you
know, goal, that will be the consequence
of your commitment to doing the job
well, or to making sure you have the
skills and the knowledge that you need in
order to achieve that longer term goal.
Even in personal relationships uh,
you can't just go up to someone
and say, I want to be your friend,
or I want to be your lover.
Uh, you first have to invest some
time and effort into getting to
know that person, uh, giving that
person a chance to get to know you.
Uh, they have to like you, you have
to like them, you know, at that
level, you build up a connection and
emotional connection or a connection
of respect, uh, which then will lead
to the result, the long-term but
in a way indirect result, that that
person and you will become friends or
lovers or whatever the case may be.
So there's no sort of short circuit
there's no, you know, jumping ahead
of yourself, you have to first find
that short term direct goal that
you can focus on that's going to
lead you to your longer term goal.
Maybe I'm not making any sense here.
When I bring it back to language
learning, what does it mean?
You have to find something to like
in the language you're learning.
Uh, if you cannot find anything to
like, anything of interest, you're
going to have a very tough time.
You can't just say, I would
like to be fluent in English
because I need it for my job.
I would like to be fluent in
German or Chinese, because it's
going to be good for my career.
You actually have to find something
in Chinese culture, in German culture
and eh, whatever Japanese, French,
Russia, something that you like.
You don't have to like everything.
Uh, similarly it helps if you
find a friend, but you don't have
to like all Chinese, Russians,
Japanese, French, you name it.
But you have to find some people
that you like, you have to find some
aspects of the language that you like.
I often quote this expression in French...
in other words, we, our appetite develops
as we are eating, but that's assume...
that assumes that you're
eating something that you like.
So, uh, you know, you have to
find that something, and that
takes a bit of looking around.
It takes a bit of patience and
unfortunately it's often difficult.
I have found it difficult at times to
find content that I'm interested in
at my level in the language, because I
know that if I can engage myself with
content of interest, the learning of
the language will look after itself.
If I do enough listening and reading
on things of interest, but I have
to find those things of interest and
in some languages that's difficult
to do because you either have a
lot of very uninteresting beginner
material, or you have material
that is, you know, intended for the
native speaker and is too difficult.
And it's sort of hard to find
content that's going to lead you
towards the ultimate, you know,
most satisfying type of material.
I think that's something that
we want to do better at LingQ.
Uh, we're trying to bring in, uh, a
greater variety of material from different
sources, including YouTube, where
people just have to click to get it.
They don't have to search for it so
that they can kind of just fall into
things of interest to them and make that
commitment to learning about those things
of interest, that commitment to enjoying
whatever it is that they're interested in.
And then recognizing that by doing that,
the longer-term goal of becoming fluent
in the language will take care of itself.
So, you know, it's perhaps a bit
of a confusing rant here, but it's
something that I have felt all along
in my life, whether in my professional
life, when I've often felt, if you do
your job well, you can't just say, I
want to succeed, I want to make money.
No, you actually have to invest in
providing uh, service, uh, even working
for a large corporation, you have to
give before you can get, you have to
give more, you can't sort of "when his
coffee break?", uh, "what's in it for
me?", you actually have to make that
investment in providing, you know, service
or working hard or developing your skills
in order to achieve that longer-term
goal of success or money or whatever.
And the same with language learning.
You have to commit yourself to something
of interest and your devouring those
things of interest and your language
skills will develop as a result.
So it's something that I've experienced.
I don't know if this makes sense.
I hope it is encouraging.
And for people who maybe are at a sort
of a doldrums stage where they feel
they're not progressing and, uh, you
know, they're not, uh, enjoying the
process, try a little harder to find
something that's going to turn your crank.
That's going to be, you know, interesting.
So that it'll take you to the final goal,
which is the fluency and the comfort
level in the language you're learning.
So there you have it.
Thank you for listening and I'll
leave a couple of videos that
might be of interest to you.
Thank you, bye for now.